the apocalypse is here ladies and
gentlemen and so is my breakdown of
American Horror Story apocalypse sorry
it's taken a few days to get this out
but I was busy finishing my Castle Rock
explain series but enough about that
we're here for the end of the world so
let's get into it
socialite Coco st. Pierre Vanderbilt is
getting her hair done by famous
hairstylist mr. gallant or as the French
say get long in fact she even says he
could be the next Chris McMillan which
for those of you who aren't on the rodeo
drive-- socialite scene is a famous
real-life Hollywood stylist also huge
points for the makeup artist who even
put glitter on Evan Peters fingernails
Mallory played here by Billie lourd
Carrie Fisher's daughter is Coco's
assistant who really wants Coco to have
her finally pressed juice because
they're so in right now but then
something even worse than a bad haircut
happens ballistic missile is inbound for
la Coco's billionaire father calls and
informed Sergius four spots reserved for
the family in the event of a nuclear
fallout but because he's in Hong Kong he
and the fam will make it the signal goes
out after what can only be assumed as a
nuclear bomb hitting the city Coco's
boyfriend played here by Billy on the
street is that work busy preparing a
six-part limited series of Free Willy
numerous international strikes have been
confirmed and Coco tells him to meet her
at the airport mr. Gowan comes to get
his Nana Evie a widow of a former MGM
studio owner she tells them it's all
fake news you are fake news in that
she'll bring the burnt champagne which
for you non millionaire widows of major
Hollywood studios means a bottle of
champagne that was frozen at one point
and lost some of its prestige kind of
like Nana Evie or self Coco says she'll
give Mallory her brothers tickets and
she needs her assistant she's helpless
without her and Mallory completely
ditches her family and agrees to go
these dudes have apparently decided it's
a great time to steal some fruit before
somebody's body comes crashing on to the
car team coco arrives at the airport and
i love how these dudes are casually just
doing their jobs even though the world
is ending that's commitment the driver
here has some sweet Mad Max gloves and I
gotta say he's pretty badass mr. Galan
rolls up with Nana Evie and begs her to
let them on after all who's gonna do her
hair when the world ends the airport
workers then decide to turn on them
for the plane jason statham over here
fights them off as cocoa releases brach
from his monogamy arrangement and they
escaped from the ravaging horde and can
we all just have a moment of silence for
this woman who tried to steal some meat
Roxie's Coco's plane fly overhead as he
leaves her with some parting words of
love I wouldn't be surprised if we see
this character make a return later on in
the series in the plane Mallory checks
to see where they're going but the
pilots are gone and even worse the
stewardess a bomb blast goes off and for
a brief moment you can see the plane
automatically adjust suggesting it's an
automatic plane or mysterious force
controlling it flashback 40 minutes
before the bomb and were introduced to
Timmy who's equally awaiting his results
from UCLA and he gets in way to go Timmy
and did you catch American Horror Story
Easter egg of pepper being one of the
male recipients then dad comes in being
a total buzzkill explaining it's World
War 3 but before they can think of a
plan two agents from the cooperative
storm in explaining that Timothy has
been selected to survive because of his
exceptional genetic makeup this video
has been sponsored by ancestry DNA he
refuses to go when he's forcefully taken
by super soldiers and locked in an
underground bunker there he meets Emily
before the bomb goes off apparently his
super genetics make him susceptible to
crying two weeks later they're taken to
outpost three one of ten around the
world built in minimal fallout zones
which is a bit odd since if they were
built in minimal fallout zones they
would a either have known where the
bombs were to hit beforehand or be built
them really really fast which we'll find
out later they didn't Timmy and Emily
are given hazmat suits and dropped off
before being greeted by the welcoming
committee kylo Ren leads them across a
field where they see two people dressed
in Amish clothing pleading that they
won't do it again and before being shot
the mass these guys wear are eerily
similar to the plague doctor mask from
medieval times the extended noses were
used to stuff herbes and spices to ward
off miasma the belief that disease was
spread through the air down in the
bunker their decontaminated and we catch
a brief glimpse of Kathy Bates's
character Mead who will later learn as
the head of security for the bunker
Sarah Paulson arrives playing Wilhelmina
Venable and welcomes them to
post three her last name sounding a lot
like venerable which is a common epithet
used in Christian theology to denote
someone who should be given respect
based on their age character or wisdom
she says the bomb was a cleansing fire
and that this is a new beginning the
cooperative the organization in charge
of putting this all together is a
collection of the dozen greatest minds
mankind has to offer the twelve are
known as the visionaries and my guesses
we'll get to meet some of them later on
there aren't any generators down here
but there is some form of electricity
considering the keycard used to get in
and the elevator Timmy and Emily are
told they're purples and assigned their
own Suites Purple's are elite the worthy
chosen to survive unlike the greys where
the worker ants and the outpost itself
is even designed like an anthill with
multiple winding pathways Emily asked
what Wilhelmina's role is in all of this
to which she responds she's the strong
right arm of the co-operative and down
here there are rules
they aren't allowed to leave due to the
risk of canker pus monsters and worst of
all no unauthorised copulation of any
kind which was what these two were
apparently doing
Timmy takes a shower when he sees 666 in
the condensation a voice whispers beware
Timothy
now this is a huge loose threat because
we don't come back to either of these by
the end of the episode in time for
cocktails it looks like they're wearing
a tire from the 1800s south which leads
me to believe they're somewhere in
Louisiana which would tie into season
threes kovin mr. gallon complains about
the same song being played every night
calling occupants of interplanetary
craft by the carpenters a song about
telepathy and reaching out to other
worlds Mallory has been relegated to a
gray and pleads to koko for her to go to
venable and make her a purple Venable
rings a bell indicating their delicious
cube dinners are ready each cube
containing every vitamin they need and
cocoa ain't havin it she wants real food
like Pirate's Booty Venable puts her in
her place and explains the gravity of
the situation they only have 18 months
of nutrition stocked and if they want to
survive they need to rationed carefully
not to mention there's been a perimeter
alert something penetrated the ground a
carrier pigeon with a message from their
benefactors three out of the ten
outposts have been overrun they're the
last of humanity
the last vestiges of civilized life Mead
is informed by mrs. lurch that there's a
spike in contamination coming from the
room someone has broken the clean rule
the Geiger counter a machine used to
detect radiation identifies the culprits
mr. gallant and Stu they're sent to the
decontamination showers where Stu is
shot because his levels are too high at
night miss Venable and Mead hold a
secret meeting where they break their
own rules by wearing purple outfits
Venable says they're the only ones that
matter and we learn Stu was set up Mead
put the counter to a higher sensitivity
this was either to keep them in control
or to thin the herd they play an old
1940's Whitman set of old maid a
Victorian card game for two or more
players probably deriving from an
ancient gambling game in which the loser
pays for the drinks the drinks here
being mineral water
they both relish the pain they caused
their captives and how they're
undermining the cooperative by making up
their own rules Venable says there is no
cooperative it's only them which doesn't
necessarily mean the co-operative
doesn't exist
it just means they've gone rogue the
others are still getting over the death
of Stu when Venable arrives as a
consolation she's prepared at bonne
bouche a French word for treat another
hint this could be taking place in the
south apparently they have resources for
special occasions Venable uses this
occasion to stress how it's important to
follow the rules for everyone's safety
gallant takes out what looks like a
tooth before everyone realizes that the
stew they're eating is well stew the
group argues whether or not the food was
actually stew when the radio changes to
Maureen McGovern's morning after
believing the co-operative is saying
hang on we're coming for you
that is until 18 months past and if you
recall that's how long their supplies
would last no one has come and nuclear
winter has taken over Timmy and Emily
are together stating that even in all
this death something was born which
could mean they broke a rule and a
baby's on the way or simply that their
love was born Venable cuts back supplies
stating they'll need to go to half a
cube a day if they want to survive
mutiny kicks in with Mallory stating I
say we take our chances outside since
when do they let a Great Auk mr. gallant
is about to be put in his place by mrs.
lurch when the alarm goes off indicating
a perimeter breach
a horse-drawn carriage
with a member of the co-operative
Michael Landon and you know this guy
means business because his badge says
unlimited clearance but look here at the
signature for president of the
co-operative it looks eerily like the
word Lucifer and his ID number ends in
666 the same number found in Timmy
shower and the number of the devil
inside we get our first look of Michael
Langdon who looks like he just came off
the set of interview with a vampire
which coincidentally enough is also
partly set in Louisiana Meade kills one
of the horses because it's contaminated
and we get our first brief glimpse of
what could be the pus monsters taking
its corpse into the woods to be eaten
back in the bunker Langdon tells Venable
that three more outposts have been
overrun and three won't make it until
the end of the year leaving their
outpost as the only one left but he's
here to change that there's another
facility an impregnable sanctuary with
enough food for a decade but it's
reserved only for those worthy of
survival he's here to weed out the
worthy which could mean next episode
could be a bloodbath I hope you'll stay
tuned with me for more HS breakdowns and
remember until next time daddy loves you
very much
[Music]